James good to have you with us so I
think we've had the two minute warning
we're expecting the Attorney General
Merrick Garland to speak in a few
minutes time but just give us the
background of what has happened here and
what we can expect the AG to potentially
say
Yeah by we have a timeline we have the
discovery of documents in properties
belonging to Joe Biden Discovery one in
a building in Washington DC an office
building 10 documents Discovery number
two as you've just said as we've just
heard was in his garage in Wilmington
Delaware in his garage and in an
adjoining room so
Republicans are saying that's extremely
similar to a situation involving the man
who preceded him Donald Trump he had
hundreds of documents in Mar-A-Lago and
it took an FBI raid to retrieve many of
them team Biden are saying look okay
there are similarities but there are key
differences for a kickoff Donald Trump
resisted in Grand style
the Attorney General Merrick Garland has
approached elector and he's now speaking
let's listen in
to Department of Justice regulations
governing such matters
in keeping with those regulations I have
today notified the designated members of
each house of Congress for the
appointment
I'm joined today by John lausch the U.S
attorney for the northern district of
Illinois who conducted the initial
investigation into the matter that I
will describe today
on the evening of November 4th 2022 the
National Archives of office of Inspector
General
contacted a prosecutor at the Department
of Justice
it informed him that the White House had
notified the archives that documents
bearing classification markings were
identified at the office of the Penn
Biden Center for diplomacy and Global
engagement located in Washington D.C
that office was not authorized for
storage of classified documents
the prosecutor was also advised that
those documents had been secured in an
archives facility
on November 9th the FBI commenced an
assessment consistent with standard
protocols to understand whether
classified information had been
mishandled in violation of federal law
on November 14th pursuant to section
600.2 B of the special counsel
regulations I assigned U.S attorney
lausch to conduct an initial
investigation to inform my decision
whether to appoint a special counsel
Mr laosch has served as a U.S attorney
in Chicago since 2017. before that he
spent more than a decade as an assistant
U.S attorney in that same office
I selected him to conduct the initial
investigation because I was confident
his experience would ensure that it
would be done professionally and
expeditiously
on December 20th President Biden's
personal counsel informed Mr lauch that
additional documents bearing
classification markings were identified
in the garage of the president's private
residents in Wilmington Delaware
President Biden's Council informed Mr
laust that those documents were among
other records from the period of the
president's Service as vice president
the FBI went to the location and secured
those documents
on January 5th 2023 Mr lausch briefed me
on the results of his initial
investigation and advised me that
further investigation by a special
counsel was warranted
based on Mr lausch's initial
investigation I concluded that under the
special counsel regulations it was in
the public interest to appoint a special
counsel
in the days since while Mr laosch
continued the investigation the
department identified Mr Herr for
appointment as special counsel
this morning President Biden's personal
counsel called Mr lauch and stated that
an additional document bearing
classification markings was identified
at the president's personal residence in
Wilmington Delaware
when I first contacted Mr lausch about
this matter he said he could lead the
initial investigation but would be
unable to accept any longer-term
assignment because he would be leaving
the department in early 2023 for the
private sector
U.S attorney lausch and his team of
prosecutors and agents have conducted
this initial investigation with
professionalism and speed
I am grateful to them
earlier today I saw I signed an order
appointing Robert Herr a special counsel
for the matter I've just described
the document authorizes him to
investigate whether any person or entity
violated the law in connection with this
matter
the special counsel will not be subject
to the day-to-day supervision of any
official of the department but he must
comply with the regulations procedures
and policies of the department
Mr Herr has a long and distinguished
career as a prosecutor in 2003 he joined
the Department's Criminal Division where
he worked on counter-terrorism corporate
fraud and appellate matters
from 2007 until 2014 Mr Herr served as
an assistant U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland where he prosecuted
matters ranging from violent crime to
financial fraud
in 2017 Mr hurry joined the Department
as the principal associate Deputy
Attorney General
in 2018 he was nominated and confirmed
to serve as a U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland
as U.S attorney he supervised some of
the Department's more important National
Security public corruption and other
high-profile matters
I will ensure that Mr Herr receives all
the resources he needs to conduct his
work
as I have said before
I strongly believe that the normal
processes of this department can handle
all investigations with integrity
but under the regulations the
extraordinary circumstances here require
the appointment of a special counsel for
this matter
this appointment underscores for the
public the Department's commitment to
both Independence and accountability and
particularly sensitive matters and to
making decisions indisputably guided
only by the facts and the law
I am confident that Mr Herr will carry
out his responsibility in an even-handed
and Urgent manner and in accordance with
the highest traditions of this
department
thank you all
things about this investigation sir well
we've been listening that to the U.S
attorney general of Merrick Garland uh
giving a statement to the assembled uh
news media there saying that a special
counsel has now been appointed to
investigate the discovery the second uh
batch of classified documents found in a
property owned by President Biden let's
bring our U.S correspondent James
Matthews back in uh for more on this
who's listening in as well to the
attorney general there and James as we
said and as you suggested earlier the
special counsel has been appointed uh
Robert her
um Eric Garland saying extraordinary
circumstances require a special counsel
to be put in place to investigate this
yeah the extraordinary circumstances
indeed the same extraordinary
circumstances really that involved
Donald Trump and by association that's
why we have a special counsel looking
into president Trump effectively what's
happened is that the investigation has
been outsourced the manual looking at
there is America's prosecutor-in-chief
the U.S attorney general a man put into
position by Joe Biden now when it came
to the Trump investigation he appointed
a special counsel for that because uh in
the interest of public perception a
perception that shouldn't uh they
shouldn't interpret any bias in the
investigation so uh abiding the point he
investigating Donald Trump when Biden
when Trump announced he was running for
president that wouldn't be a good look
for the justice department therefore a
special counsel was appointed what Mary
Garland is saying here is it in the
interests of Independence accountability
and those things being seen to be
followed through that's why he's
appointing a special counsel in this
regards it's what Republicans have been
calling for they've been saying Luke if
you have a special counsel an
independent investigator looking into
Trump then Joe Biden has to be held to
the same standards there has to be
parity in the investigations because the
situations the circumstances are very
similar that's what Republicans say team
Biden and Democrats say something quite
different they point out that in the
case of trump he had hundreds of
documents which he withheld despite
repeated requests over many months and
it took a knock on the door by the FBI
for him to hand over the classified
documents that he retained that's quite
different the Democrats say from Joe
Biden who discovered some documents
and very quickly immediately handed them
over to the National Archives and kept
the justice department fully informed so
there is that claim of transparency by
the Biden camp that will undoubtedly be
tested by the special counsel Robert her
among the first questions he will ask
surely are who put these documents there
how did they get here how did they get
there what information did these
classified documents contain how
sensitive was it and how secure were the
conditions
in which they were kept I know that
already aids to Joe Biden and these
documents relate to his time as vice
president during the shift from the
White House the AIDS involved have been
questioned about you know the functions
that They carried out and their movement
of documents so that's where the
investigations are centered at the
moment was it a practical error uh
unbeknown to those committing that
particular mistake that's where the
investigations are at this very early
stage I suppose the worry for Biden will
be that an investigation you know can
lead any number of places we've seen
that in the past with special counsels
independent councils investigating
sitting presidents Bill Clinton uh among
them but Donald Trump I mean you know
his camper Cocker who bear in mind he's
facing a criminal investigation by a
special counsel staring down the barrel
of a criminal trial if that's the way
that investigation proceeds they are
very strongly making the point that
there are parallels here but you know
we'll see how the investigations pan out
there was obstruction or there appears
there are certainly allegations of
instruction when it comes to Donald
Trump uh Joe Biden's Camp are making the
point that basically it was an innocent
mistake and it's worth making the point
as well that uh the crime it's not crime
to actually be in possession of
classified documents the crime is
unlawfully withholding them with the
knowledge that you are indeed
withholding very sensitive material that
belongs either in the white house or at
the National Archives and James you you
raise that equivalence that's being made
between the two situations for current
president and the former president and I
wonder how that equivalence is going
down for supporters of each of the men
are they seeing that as being exactly
the same and with disappointment now the
special counselor how do you think that
will play into the idea that these are
very similar situations
well I think in terms of the headline
there is a similarity isn't there a
special counsel for both investigations
and on the face of it there's no doubt
there is a considerable overlap but you
know in this country where partisan
politics reign supreme you have one side
uh screaming blue the other side
screaming red and in terms of the
Republicans Trump supporting Republicans
they are saying this is exactly the same
you have a a president in possession of
classified documents and if an
investigation into Biden is going to be
shaped towards an innocent mistake then
the [ __ ] the same should apply to Donald
Trump on in terms of Team Biden and Joe
Biden himself he said he was very
surprised when he was first asked about
it a couple of days ago the word from
the Biden Camp is very much that this
has been an innocent State you know
there are very few documents where he is
concerned compared to what seems to have
been quite an operation to retain
several hundred documents and despite
repeated requests telephone requests
subpoenas Donald Trump held on to
documents and resisted all attempts to
get you know to to hand them over and it
took the an FBI morning raid at his home
at Mar-A-Lago in Florida to take them
back but the warning for Joe Biden will
be any kind of Investigation I suppose
an investigation on the one hand will
bring everything out into the open and
give the transparency that we still need
with relation in relation to the the
Biden documents but you know any kind of
Investigation particularly at a time
when there are many questions about
Biden his finances his son Hunter Biden
the hunter Biden laptop story you know
with that all in the air
um it may not it may be that he doesn't
welcome the presence of a special
counsel anywhere near him or his Affairs
remember
can a star independent Council who
looked into the clintons that started
out although fairly innocent enough
looked at looking at an Arkansas estate
agency deal in the first instance
but that evolved into an investigation
that led to the moniker Lewinsky sex
scandal a sex scandal that shamed Bill
Clinton's presidency so you know it's
not great news for Joe Biden it must be
said uh and of the two camps between
Trump and Biden it's certainly the Trump
camp that at the moment are making most
noise about this okay James Finn I
really appreciate that thank you